opinions expressed on this program are
those of the guests appearing on the
program and do not necessarily reflect
the views and opinions of eight news now
or next our media group
we're always trying to warn tenants
don't ignore a notice tonight on
politics now an eviction moratorium is
extended the competing legal decisions
in nevada
and efforts to hand out millions of
dollars in rental assistance
i think the very positive news is that
we're seeing a lot of people who are
going back
to work and leaving unemployment what
happens when unemployment runs out
we talk to the head of dieter about what
to expect when federal programs end
in a month i don't want to mandate i'm
tired of just giving people mandate
and a plea from governor sisselek what
he's asking businesses to do so more
vaccine mandates won't be necessary
from eight news now this is politics now
the cdc has extended its eviction
moratorium until
october 3rd unless the courts step in
thanks for joining us i'm vanessa murphy
john is off
president joe biden acknowledged that
the supreme court previously
indicated congress not cdc would have to
extend a moratorium
the existing moratorium was not
constitutional
it wouldn't stand despite that
acknowledgment the democrats in nevada's
congressional delegation
all applauded the move biden said he
hoped it would buy time to hand out
rental assistance money while it worked
its way
through the courts the moratorium
applies to areas with high rates of
spread of covit 19
and clark county definitely falls into
that category
landlords can still move ahead with
evictions but the cdc moratorium
may prevent that final step of kicking
tenants out of their homes
barbara buckley who heads the legal aid
center of southern nevada points out
a decision was recently made in the las
vegas justice court
stating the moratorium doesn't apply to
nevada residents
she says she disagrees with the decision
and she believes it will be overturned
but it's an example of why tenants need
to take action to protect themselves
we're a little worried that people hear
the word moratorium
and they think they don't have to do
anything the cdc
moratorium stops the service
of a final eviction order for 60 days
but it's not a final solution
for the rental problem a spokeswoman for
governor steve siselek says the state
is expecting more guidance from the cdc
in the coming days
buckley offers five steps for tenants if
they receive an eviction notice
we have those on our website eight
newsnow dot com
right now about nine thousand people in
clark county are waiting to find out if
their applications for rental help will
be approved
one local business owner told me it's
not just tenants who are struggling
right now though
he says landlords and property managers
are left to pick up the pieces
literally while some tenants are facing
an eviction crisis
the owner of a property management
company says some landlords are facing a
crisis of their own
finding some properties left like this
after tenants are kicked out
you can see a window broken belongings
left behind
the place is just trashed what other
businesses vilified for trying to stay
in business
but yet property managers are owners are
derrick molinger owns vice realty which
he says manages about 650
units throughout the las vegas valley he
tells the i-team
this is a frequent problem closet
doors ripped off properties destroyed
after tenants are locked out
we don't just file a piece of paper kick
someone out because we don't like them
if the eviction moratorium ends
mullinger estimates he'll soon be
locking out tenants in
20 units for unpaid rent something he
says
could have been prevented if they
applied for rental assistance
they don't want it because they see us
as us against them
and it's really not that way we have a
symbiotic relationship i need tenants
tenants need me
while evictions are expected to increase
rent in southern nevada
is also going up i was calling to tell
them that i was going to pay it on
friday
the i-team first contacted mullinger
after we met his
tenant tommy wesley monday he told the
i-team his rent was raised by 275
dollars which mullinger
confirms that's a really big jump how
can you justify that
uh same way the gas station justifies
going from 243 in january to 4.11
today same way home depot charges 70 for
a sheet of plywood now
and it used to be in the teens same way
when i go to the grocery store
prices went up he says in many cases
he's willing to work with tenants like
wesley by giving them another month
at the old rate but he also has
obligations to the landlords he
represents
they're trying to make a living some of
them count on this for the retirement
some of them
yes they have a bunch of units and this
is a business for them the majority of
people it's not that
mullinger says at the end of the day he
just wants the rent money whether it's
from the rental assistance
or directly from tenants
mullinger says he is frustrated with how
slow the process is going with the
applications
the county is approving about 800
applications a week
we've put a list of resources at eight
newsnow dot com it includes a link for
rental assistance
what tenants should do if they receive
an eviction notice again
and information on a program for
landlords
governor steve siselek says he is not
planning another shutdown or capacity
limits but
he's exploring other steps like making
the vaccine mandatory in specific
situations that can include at colleges
and universities and for health care
workers
sisilak also says he's asked his medical
advisors how to make
large gatherings safer at this point he
says he is not inclined to push
businesses and organizers to require
vaccine
passports like new york city is doing
i don't want to mandate i'm tired of
just giving people mandates i want the
cooperation coming back
and they're taking the first step and
saying governor we're with you because i
believe they are with us
we're all together on this to say that
look this is how we can do it better
if we do abc it'll be better that's what
i'm hopeful will come forward from the
industry
the nevada hospital association reports
overcrowding
and staffing shortages and that nearly
all patients hospitalized with covid19
are not vaccinated two major federal
programs people are getting unemployment
from right now are ending
in a month there are about 39 000 on pua
and 69 000 on the federal extended
benefits peuc
so what happens when they run out i
talked with the director of the state's
department of employment training
and rehabilitation the pula
and the peuc end
september 6th right so what do you
expect to happen
after that as far as those people who
have been receiving that money
these are congressional programs that
are extensions
or new programs that congress created in
response to the pandemic and they do
expire as you say the first part of
september
and what will happen is they end and
unless congress takes action which we
currently don't have any expectation
that they will
do anything uh these these programs are
ending and folks will file and get their
last
uh week of benefits this is actually
what happened in the
great recession as well benefits were
expended
extended for uh ultimately 99 weeks
and then they they ended is there any
alternative
type of program unemployment program
they could try to apply for or that's it
the pua program is for gig workers and
that was a new thing that congress
created to help people that
pretty much didn't qualify for regular
ui
so if the only folks who are going to be
available for an
another program like regular ui are
folks who
worked a regular job with regular wages
um in the last year and uh by and large
most the folks we're seeing uh did not
do that so they would not
qualify obviously covid19
and the pandemic is a fluid
situation um but are there any project
are there any projections about when
nevada
could return to those pre-pandemic
unemployment numbers northern nevada and
rural nevada have recovered
a a large number of the jobs that they
lost
at the beginning of the pandemic and
it's las vegas that is really
the um outlier where we're still looking
for those jobs to come back
so it kind of varies um
and i and because a lot of the jobs are
in hospitality
uh and entertainment in las vegas
uh i think it really does depend on the
covid situation in terms of
the recovery i think the very positive
news is that we're seeing
a lot of people who are going back to
work and leaving unemployment
are going into new jobs and they're
actually making a little more money than
they made on their last job
shifting gears to fraud we know that's
been a big issue
are there any estimates at this point
of how much fraud there has been
i have shared several times that kind of
at a super high level
um you know we at the beginning the
pandemic
unemployment was about 30 which means we
would expect to
see about half a million unemployment
applications and that's about how many
people got some
unemployment benefits but we actually
saw
over two million unemployment
applications
and most of those we didn't pay and
unfortunately a few legit people got
caught up in that
caferetta also said they plan to use
american rescue act money to pay off the
unemployment
unemployment trust fund debt and put it
back at zero
a proposal to pay people in clark county
to get the covid vaccine
is on pause for now commissioner tick
sagerbloom proposed paying people
100 dollars to get vaccinated
commissioners also briefly talked about
the possibility of mandating county
employees to get the vaccine or show
proof of a negative test
they'll talk about both of those in a
few weeks
nevada congressman mark amade revealed
he has been recovering from cancer
amadeus said he has had surgery and
treatments and is recovering well
he told the associated press he did not
reveal this in september when he learned
the diagnosis
because he didn't want it to affect the
november election
and mayor carolyn goodman shared she
tested positive for covid19 last month
she is fully vaccinated
i have no idea because i'm out there all
the time
probably inappropriately hugging and
touching people
all the time and that's how i choose to
operate
and that's how i will continue to choose
to operate
i get to choose how i am
mayor goodman says her symptoms were
mild and she was able to recover
and get back to work after 10 days
making the grade next on politics now
teachers and students will have to
adjust to new grading policies at ccsd
why they have been put in place and the
reaction from
inside the classroom plus the polls that
show
a precarious position for california's
governor as a recall election approaches
clark county school district students
head back to class monday
while many families are hoping to to get
back to some normalcy with in-person
classes there will be some changes
kate houston breaks down the new grading
policy and why some teachers say
it's lowering standards this great
change takes behaviors completely out of
the question
and it arguably at the detriment of the
student
tam lester a teacher at del sol academy
is preparing to use the new grading
guidelines
there's a lot of mixed thoughts the new
district-wide scale sets the lowest
grade at 50 percent
behaviors such as attendance
participation and late or missing
assignments
will not influence a grade during a back
to school kickoff
superintendent dr jesus jarrah says this
will create equity across the district
by having grades reflect knowledge
instead of non-academic factors
all children will have the ability
to demonstrate however lester says this
new policy takes tools that incentivize
students away from teachers
and does not instill accountability what
they will need is those learner-ready
behaviors things like focus things like
participation
things like time management and some of
these policies
are taking those away the new guidelines
were approved in early july
ccsd is currently training teachers on
how to use the new grading scale ahead
of the school year
and it's not going to happen overnight
and i think it's going to be something
that
students parents and staff will
acclimate to lester worries it may be
too big of a shift
too soon i know the district wants to
focus on intrinsic motivation and that's
beautiful but i think
we also need training with that you know
for the past history of education is
focused on classroom management
not classroom motivation kate houston 8
news now
california's governor is on the hot seat
the new polls from california that show
a recall could be successful
and who the leading candidate is to
replace him
starting to look worse for california's
governor gavin newsom
our sister program in the golden state
inside california politics released
new polling about the recall election
newsom is facing
ashley zavala breaks it down for us this
latest poll shows just within the last
couple of weeks more and more california
voters are indicating they'll support
recalling governor gavin newsom this
latest inside california politics and
emerson college poll went out into the
field over the weekend
to 1 000 california voters in this poll
46 percent said they would vote to
recall governor gavin newsom versus 48
percent who say
they would keep him in office the amount
of voters supporting the recall has
increased 3 percent since our last poll
just two weeks ago
obviously the momentum based on these
numbers are going in the wrong direction
for the governor
but there's so much happening on the
ground that it's not that surprising
considering everything happening with
covid
the opening of schools there's a lot of
anxiety amongst voters and generally
they take it out on the politicians
while voters are still split on whether
to recall the governor
most about 40 percent are still
undecided on the pick to replace him
among the candidates the front runner
here remains republican radio talk show
host larry elder
now with 23 percent of voters saying
they would pick him up seven points from
just two weeks ago
that's where we see that huge number of
democrats truly undecided of what to do
nearly 70 percent
don't know who to vote for because
there's really not an alternative for
them
to choose our pollsters found governor
newsom is losing support from hispanic
voters
54 percent of latino respondents to this
poll said that they would vote to recall
the governor this is the only racial
group with the majority indicating that
they would do so
he's going to have to make a large
impact with that group of voters
now with that said he's really
struggling with less educated voters and
i think that's where the kogit
pandemic really separates the society so
if you don't have a college degree
you seem to be more upset and you seem
to want to recall the governor
with a college degree less the case you
want to keep the governor
to give you a breakdown of the party
affiliation of those who responded to
this poll
46 percent identified as democrat about
23 percent identified as republican
and about 30 percent said no party
preference
lake levels continue to drop at lake
mead amid a historic
mega drought in the west nevada senator
catherine cortez masto says she has a
plan to help
by recycling sewage water on a large
scale
our washington d.c correspondent
alexandra lamone explains
much of california's wastewater is
treated and dumped into the pacific
but as western states continue to suffer
through a mega drought
water managers and lawmakers say
wastewater must be recycled
recycled water is going to be extremely
important not just in the west
but likely throughout the entire nation
bronson mack with the southern nevada
water authority says
southern nevada already recycles all
indoor waste water
not just from sinks and tubs but from
toilets too
they use a process of biological and
chemical processes
multi-staged filtration and then a
disinfection process
portions of western states already
recycle their wastewater but because of
the drought
climate change and population growth
experts say
larger scale water recycling is a must
we have to figure out
how we manage not the water just for the
current population
but like our southern nevada water
authority does projects 50 years in the
future
nevada senator catherine cortez masto
introduced a bill to help pay for
large-scale water recycling projects to
turn
sewage water into drinking water for
example
there's an opportunity for nevada to
partner with california for california
to actually recycle sewage water senator
cortez master's bill
is co-sponsored by california senator
alex padilla
and is so far included in the senate's
bipartisan infrastructure bill
it would provide 450 million dollars in
grants to 17 western states for
large-scale water recycling projects in
washington
alexandra limon joining us to talk about
this bill is
alexandra lamone from our washington d.c
bureau
alex you mentioned the nevada california
partnership to recycle water in the los
angeles area that may be good news for
california but
what does nevada get out of that yeah
that's right this is a really great
partnership that's going to help
try to start recycling water in the los
angeles
area so that is a huge project but
southern nevada in return for
its investment in this project is
getting something out of it they will
get a share of that water
that is being recycled or that will be
recycled in the future
in the la area but instead of you know
having to pipe it and pump it back from
california
to nevada what's going to happen is that
nevada will get
an allotment that same allotment of that
water that they will instead now be able
to take
from lake mead from the colorado river
through lake mead
in return for that investment and you
said the water recycling bill is
included in the infrastructure package
tell us about the other
major water investments included in that
package
well in addition to just the lack of
water that we're seeing in the west
because of this ongoing mega drought
conditions
another big issue that the entire
country is facing
is access to clean and safe drinking
water in a lot of places
the water infrastructure the water pipes
are just so
old they're decades old sometimes 100
years old
and they are lead leaching pipes so they
contaminate the water
in other areas there's issues with
chemical contamination of water
um and things like pfos being in the
water so the
infrastructure bill actually also
includes tens of billions of dollars
to be able to be dispersed throughout
the country to help try to deal with
some of those water contamination issues
to also make sure that the water that is
available is actually safe for people to
drink
in what to watch here's what we're
keeping an eye on next week first up
lake mead levels a federal shortage is
expected to be declared along the
colorado river in the next few weeks
that could initiate cuts in both arizona
and nevada
we're waiting to see what else happens
with it plus monday is back to school
we're watching to see how mask mandates
and all classes are going
and if more steps will be necessary this
school year thanks so much for watching
politics now you can stay up to date
online
and watch us every saturday
[Music]
you